so in the last video i talked about
curvature and the radius of curvature
and i described it purely geometrically
where i'm saying you imagine driving
along a certain road your steering wheel
locks and you're wondering what the
radius of the circle that you draw with
your car you know through whatever
surrounding fields there are on the road
as a result and the special symbol that
we have for this
for this idea of curvature is a little
kappa
and that's going to be one divided by
the radius and the reason we do that is
basically you want a large kappa a large
curvature to correspond with a sharp
turn so sharp turn small radius large
curvature but the question is how do we
describe this in a more and more
mathematical way so i'm going to go
ahead and clear up
get rid of the
circle itself and all of that radius and
just be looking at the curve itself in
its in its own right
the way you typically describe a curve
like this is parametrically so you'll
have some kind of vector valued function
s that takes in a single parameter t
and then it's going to output the the x
and y coordinates each as functions of t
and so this will be the x coordinate
the y coordinate
and in this specific case i'll just tell
you the curve that i drew happens to be
parameterized by 1
minus the sine of t
as the
x component function
actually no it's t minus sine of t and
the bottom part is 1 minus cosine of t
that's that's the curve that i drew
and the way that you're thinking about
this is for each value t you get a
certain vector that puts you at a point
on the curve and as t changes the vector
you get changes but the tip of that
vector kind of traces out the curve as a
whole
right
you know maybe
and you could imagine just the vector
drawing the curve as t varies
and the thought behind making curvature
mathematical here i'll kind of clear up
some room for myself is that you
take the tangent vectors here
so
so you might imagine like a unit tangent
vector at every given point
and you're wondering how quickly those
guys change direction
right
so with the little schematic that i have
drawn here i might call this guy i'm
just going to call this guy t1 for like
the first tangent vector t2
t3
and i haven't you know specified where
they start or anything i just want to
give a feel for you've got various
different tangent vectors and i'm just
going to say that all of them each one
of those t sub somethings
has a unit length and the idea of
curvature is to look at how quickly that
unit tangent vector changes directions
so you know you might imagine just a
completely a different space so rather
than rooting each vector on the curve
let's see what it would look like if you
just kind of write each vector in its
own right off in some other spot so this
guy here
would be t1 and then t2 points a little
bit a little bit down
and then t3 points kind of much much
more down
so all of these this would be
t1 that guy is t2 and these are the same
vectors i'm just kind of drawing them
all rooted at the same spot so it's a
little easier to see how they turn and
you want to say okay how much do you
change as you go from t1 to t2 is that a
large angle change and as you go from t2
to t3 is that a large change as well
and you can kind of see how if you have
a curve and let's say it's
if you have a curve that curves quite a
bit you know it's doing something like
that then the unit vector the unit
tangent vector at this point
changes quite rapidly over a short
distance to be something almost 90
degrees different whereas if you take
the unit vector here and see how much
does it change as you go from this point
over to this point it doesn't really
change that much
so the thought behind curvature is we're
going to take the rate of change of that
unit tangent vector so the rate of
change of t and i'm going to let capital
capital t be a function that tells you
whatever the unit tangent vector at each
point is and i'm not going to take the
rate of change in terms of you know the
the parameter little t which is what we
use to parameterize the curve because it
shouldn't matter how you parameterize
the curve maybe you're driving along it
really quickly or really slowly instead
what you want to take is the rate of
change with respect to arc length
arc length and i'm using using the
variable s here to denote arc length and
what i mean by that is if you take just
a tiny little step here
the distance of that step the actual
distance in the x y plane you'd consider
to be the arc length and if you imagine
it being really really small you're
considering that a d s a tiny change in
the arc length
so this is the quantity that we care
about how much does that unit tangent
vector change
with respect to a tiny change in the arc
length you know as we travel along let's
say it was a distance of like 0.5
right you want to know did this unit did
this unit vector change a lot or a
little bit but i should add something
here it's this tiny change in the vector
that would tell you you know what the
what the vector connecting their two
tips is um so this would be a
vector-valued quantity and curvature
itself should just be a number so what
we really care about is the size of this
guy right so what we really care about
the size of this
which is a vector-valued quantity
and that'll be an indication of just how
much the curve curves but if on a
sharper turned curve you go over that
same distance and then suddenly the the
change in the tangent vectors goes by
quite a bit um that would be telling you
it's a high curvature and in the next
video i'm going to talk through what
that looks like how you
how you think about this
tangent vector function this unit
tangent vector function and what it
looks like to take the derivative of
that with respect to arc length
it can get a little convoluted in terms
of the symbols involved and the constant
picture you should have in the back of
your mind is that circle that circle
that's hugging the curve very closely at
a certain point
and this means of taking the magnitude
of the rate of change of the unit
tangent vector with respect to arc
length is all just trying to capture
that idea